what was your process like for adapting
your own novel
into a short film great i love talking
about this
um so a little back story i had created
i created a company that does trailers
for books and novels
that sort of took off like right away
just because they had been a thing but
they weren't done very well and i was
like oh
what if we do them really well and make
them cinematic
and it it caught on and i was able to
you know through
uh producing those um really get a feel
for how to streamline
um in a way that's faithful to the the
book but at the same time isn't
obsessively clinging to plot elements
that no one is really gonna care about
who's watching a one minute trailer
so that prepared me
for about a year and a half
[Music]
to make cut because originally when i
wrote the script for the short
it was all like taking it was straight
up adaptation it was like
faithful to the details but you know i
was even talking to some of the actors
about it
about their characters like this doesn't
make sense to me i'm like you know it
wouldn't
actually unless you read the book and
then i kept hearing myself say that
and i was like well then this is for you
you're making this for yourself
not an audience and so i kind of
switched it around
and i stopped doing that and by
by just letting go and letting it evolve
into a new form like i'm faithful to
the spirit of the book i'm faithful to
most of the characters in the book
new characters emerged for the trailer
plot lines that just kind of got diluted
that weren't necessary to know at that
at that level and i think it turned into
a much more organic piece than it would
have been
had i clung to these details that you
know what i mean
and i think that's i think that's true
of any adaptation i mean
you're never going to please the people
who love the book
when you're making the film not entirely
everyone's going to have something
and why not i mean why do it if you're
just going to film the book
i feel like you got to let it evolve you
like you got to let it become
it's film it's film form or whatever i
don't know what i'm trying to say but
i think it's a separate a separate piece
altogether and you have to let it be
i like how you said you had this
realization that you were making the
film
for you and not for the audience and
then you wanted to switch it yeah
at what point did that become clear to
you during
like during pre-production and just talk
because it's an ensemble cast in the
short
and they're all representing different
characters from the book
and i realized that i was having them i
was going to ask them to perform
details that were taken straight from a
chapter but which
someone watching a one minute video or
even a four minute video isn't going to
understand the context of at all
they would after they read the novel and
went back but that's not the point of
making the video
you're trying to entice people to you
know come to you as an author and come
to
come to your book so i just let go of
that
and it was very rewarding i think it
became better
as a result and just i think that's just
true of any sort of
journey from from the page to screen is
you're not going to film the page
i mean for the most part you're going to
let it become what it needs to become
hopefully
and then you said something else that
was really fascinating which i know a
lot of adaptations
the book lovers usually slam the film
i'm thinking too speaking of david
foster wallace i think it's end of the
tour
i love the film when i okay so great and
i if you look in the comments
underneath the trailer people are just
like bashing it and i absolutely love
this film
yeah i thought it was so well done i
actually wish there was a sequel to it
i wish there was more to it but but
being at peace with the fact that
book lovers and film lovers are not
going to be have a meeting of the minds
i mean they might and i'm not saying
everyone thinks that way but
i know what comments you're talking
about in general i mean it's it's always
like well you
the hair color is wrong so therefore
this doesn't work for me
well okay i mean but don't i think
people are very literal
and they can be too literal and and you
know part of
part of adaptation is changing
you know and i think it's inherent in
the word
and you have to you have to allow that
to happen it's um
now it's tricky because i was in the
unique situation of being the director
and the author
and you know that's sort of a conflict
unless until you come to that
realization that you can just let
that part of yourself go and just put on
this hat and then do your own thing
there
um but you can i can definitely see like
being your worst
enemy in that situation and in the
beginning i definitely was
with the book trailers you have a really
amazing website is it film hyphen 14
film 14 film 14 so film 14.com
filmhyphen14.com yeah okay
and i mean that's i looked at all like
the
you have all these little book like
covers the enemy it's just amazing
you came up with the idea no not
necessarily
um so there was
no i was approached by an author around
2011 who's a friend of mine who wanted a
trailer for his book and i didn't really
know what that was at the time and
so i went on google and i looked around
and i saw that
they had been making them since like
just really poorly um like really bad
like just they put 15 minutes into it
you could see it
they just threw some slides onto imovie
and some scrolling text and that was the
thing and i'm like
wow how do you do this for 10 years and
it doesn't evolve at all
like how does that work i mean and then
i started to realize like
this is huge i mean because if you
remember at the time e-readers had just
come out and there was this question oh
is print dead
are books dead and obviously they're not
they're more popular than ever
but you know at the time that people
were saying that and thinking that
and so you know my feeling was like if
we can use
video properly we can employ independent
filmmakers in a new format
and bring people back to books and do it
cheaper than most production prices you
know the most production houses would
would charge by just keeping it really
indie driven
and that's sort of the the way i
designed the company and
how i've been looking at it ever since
but again
the one the trick to it is that you are
effectively making the author a producer
and so that comes with
you know whole special set of
circumstances and things to
to dance around but the biggest one
being like
letting go of certain plot elements in
your book
and just letting it sort of represent an
overall taste of what you're trying to
do
just to entice people it's like music
videos it's the same thing it's not like
you watch music videos even back in the
80s the the images you're seeing aren't
necessarily mirrors of what the song
lyrics are
sometimes they go their completely own
direction
and it becomes like a standalone work of
art
right how long are these book trailers
is there like a a standard
length roughly between 30 seconds 90
seconds
oh and that's all the time you have to
tell the little
things you can go longer if you want but
the ones that perform better seem to be
shorter yeah
and so it's not the just still images
with text that's moving
you're using actors yeah music
wow so then how is that working with an
author who may not be as visual or maybe
i'm
i'm that's not true they are visual
everyone's different
um i think you know there's
it's just it depends who you get it
depends who you're working with i mean
there are some
authors that come to us and they see
what we do and they're like i want that
and i you guys just do your thing and um
there's a process i mean we make
treatments for them and then we
we develop it with them so that they
know what they're getting and then we
they're involved in casting and stuff
like that um then there's others who
come in
and and they know exactly what they want
and they're like hey i wrote this script
and so we'll read it and sometimes it's
totally doable
and you know we might make suggestions
or anything like that but
there are other times when the they have
a script idea there's just
20 million dollars if you want to do it
and that's not
going to work then it's just really
helping them you know get to something
more manageable and at the same
time being faithful to what it is
they're trying to say
and then with this book trailer this
would go with their social media
right so so they would have it on their
own website or the publisher's website
ideally you have it everywhere that's
the thing you want to have it on
your author's website all the social
channels the goodreads is the amazons
and the more people posting about it the
better obviously wow and so all genres
why
a thriller non-fiction everything i mean
they're they're exceedingly popular with
young adult just because i think
that audience is more movie-minded too
like they they actually are they have a
stake in seeing
the uh material get adapted to film and
they realize that a really good trailer
is sort of
a conduit to that or could be
at least a suggestion so you hadn't
done your adaptation until you'd already
been doing other people's
right and then you finally said why
don't i try this
well i mean it was around that time i
published my book and so
i was i was in that mode so i'm like oh
we're going to do this really cool video
for it we're going to make it very
elaborate
but certainly i i think the letting go
part of it wouldn't have happened if i
hadn't
created that groove in my brain with
making the you know the trailers
originally that i made for the company
very cool yeah i recommend everybody to
go to the site it's really beautiful the
way you have all the
covers thank you
you